when psychologists like myself talk
about psychopaths in fact referring to a
distinct subset of individuals with a
specific constellation of personality
characteristics such as ruthlessness
fearlessness mental toughness
self-confidence coolness Under Pressure
emotional Detachment they all sound
great I mean yeah they sound pretty good
there are certain Psychopathic
characteristics that in the right
context in the right combinations at the
right levels with the right intentions
can predispose you to success and also
benefit Society so I did a survey called
the Great British psychopath survey and
the survey was unique in the sense that
what I wanted to find out was what were
the most Psychopathic professions in the
UK number one with CEOs yep yep perhaps
not surprisingly number two
yes that is worrying yeah
um we're psychos and let's find out if
you're a psycho and you're a psycho
people can follow what follow up with
this test yeah you can feel the tension
Rising here so I surprised myself
massively well now for fifth will want
to be the center of attention
because that is the end goal for them
they want to be the center of attention
they want to be in the Limelight a
psychopath doesn't need to be the center
of attention for its own sake but it's a
means to an end for a psychopath so for
a psychopath being the center of
attention being in the Limelight
gives them access to power and if being
a center of attention is the primary way
of getting that power then that's what
they will do
foreign
ometry I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine kitten and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People a brilliant
guest today is a psychologist and
best-selling author Dr Kevin Dunn
welcome to trigonometry thanks
Constantine thanks Francis I'll tell you
what you know if you want on this
conversation they know why you got mail
well you're you are the professor for
the public understanding of psychology
in Australia that's true so we would
like to publicly understand psychology
which is exactly why we've got you on we
also like to understand if either of us
is a psychopath so we'll do that test
later on I thought what you were going
to say was you want to publicly
understand Australia
that would be a challenge but uh welcome
to the show for anyone who's not
familiar with you tell everybody who are
you uh how are you where you are what's
been your journey through life uh well
I'm uh Professor Kevin Dunn as you say
um I am a psychologist a research
psychologist research scientist
um and I originally started off studying
uh the art of persuasion and social
influence
um and I wrote a book
um called flypnosis like hypnosis but
flypnosis the art of Split Second
persuasion
and in that uh book was a chapter on
Psychopaths because in order to write
the book I spent
um
best part of a year hanging out with
some of the world's top con artists
um so I'm not talking about you like you
know your people that do over old ladies
gas meters but there used to be a show
called hustle on the BBC I remember it
not the real house of what the drama
with Adrian Leicester yeah and they
really are teams of people that go
around who are that good right
so I studied them
um so my my research background PhD was
in Social influence and persuasion
um but um I wanted to find out whether
there was a kind of persuasion that was
irresistible so a lot of people uh
before flypnosis came out thought that a
lot of persuasion was very much about
due process and negotiation you get it
right as many times as you get it wrong
um but I I heard a story about Winston
Churchill
uh now there's a lot of stories about
Winston Churchill
um a lot of which are apocryphal but
this one is true which got me thinking
about the art of persuasion the science
of social influence in a very different
way
and the story went that one evening at
the end of a lavish party for
Commonwealth dignitaries in London
Winston Churchill spot for fellow guests
about to steal a solid silver assault
seller from the table now caught on the
one hand between the desire to avoid uh
an undignified contractor and the equal
and opposite to their desire on the
other not to let the bastard get away
with it what is Churchill to do well
what he does is he picks up the matching
silver Pepper Pot puts it inside his own
coat pocket wanders over to the
gentleman in question takes it out sets
it down on the table in front of them
and Whispers surreptitiously in his ear
I think they've seen us we'd better put
them back to the problem resolved simply
elegantly and without any further Ado
now when I heard that story I thought to
myself I wonder if persuasion is like
that in theory all the time is there a
key to every situation that if we could
somehow find it would resolve it but 99
of the time we can't find it
so uh flypnosis was about my search for
that key
um and in order to do that I interviewed
lots and lots of different people uh put
together a lot of different research
across social influence and persuasion
and part of that of course involved
um interviewing and spending time with
what I call the Evil Geniuses of
persuasion so your world's topcon
artists who
um unlike me as the boffin have learned
it all from first principles who've
learned it all from the streets from
living on their whips and I wanted to
know who who knew more about persuasion
me me the buffing the nerd or them the
guys you know basically as I say derived
it from first principles it turned out
it was a bit of a draw so I knew all the
technical terms but they knew how to do
it and they are Evil Geniuses of
persuasion anyway they were all of them
without uh without exception Psychopaths
um now you don't need to be violent to
be a psychopath
um we'll come on to that in a minute but
they just had no conscience no remorse
they were pretty ruthless and they could
destroy people's lives not by violence
but by fraud and deception and is that
the definition of a psychopath the
willingness to inflict harm on other
people for your own benefit without
caring about it no that's no no that's
that's more a sadist now you do get
sadistic Psychopaths but um uh it's
interesting when people when you hear
the word psychopath people instantly
think of in real life serial killers
like Ted Bundy and on the Silver Screen
of course your Hannibal lectures uh but
actually Constantine when psychologists
like myself talk about psychopaths in
fact referring to a distinct subset of
individuals with a specific
constellation of personality
characteristics such as ruthlessness
fearlessness mental toughness
self-confidence coolness Under Pressure
uh emotional Detachment they all sound
like yeah they sound pretty good yeah
well you have a view of focus charm
Charisma right and of course those
trademark deficits are in conscience and
empathy that you hear so much about now
you've put your finger on it none of
those traits is necessarily a problem in
itself in fact all of them dialed up at
the right levels and deployed within the
right context can actually prove rather
useful the key lies in context and level
so let me explain that because this is
crucial imagine for example that the
qualities that I've just told you about
comprise the uh hodgepodge of knobs and
sliders on a personality mixing desk
okay so if you twiddle them up and down
in various combinations
you're going to arrive at two
conclusions the first is that there is
no one-size-fits-all objectively correct
setting at which those dials may be
positioned but rather
um it will invariably depend on timing
upon a particular set of circumstances
you might happen to find yourself in the
second is the by its very nature they're
going to be certain jobs or professions
are going to demand that some of those
mixing deciles be turned up just a
little bit higher than average demand
what I call some Precision engineered
psychopathy so let me give an example
um imagine you've got the skill set to
be a top surgeon right but that you lack
the ability to uh emotionally disengage
from the person you're operating on
you're not going to cut it are you well
actually quite literally yeah quite
literally
um imagine you've got the skill set to
be a top lawyer but do you like the
almost pathological self-confidence to
be the center of attention in the middle
of a of a packed courtroom that
narcissism to be the big shot in front
of a jury again it's not going to work
is it imagine you've got the Strategic
and financial Financial smarts to be a
top business person
but that you let the ruthless sister
fire someone if they're underperforming
or the coolness Under Pressure to ride
out a storm or the sheer balls necessary
to take a calculated risk when
appropriate now those characteristics
are just outlined for you there rufus's
fearlessness self-confidence coincidence
under pressure and emotional detachment
as you rightly say Constantine comprised
five core characteristics of the
psychopathic personality I certainly
wouldn't say they were dysfunctional in
those contexts
um I don't know about you but I
certainly wouldn't and that's the key
when when flypnosis came out about the
con men about about the the rules of
persuasion was there a DNA of persuasion
that you know would make examples like
the Churchill kind of um story
um available to all of us were we all
capable of doing that kind of thing
could we all find the key when that book
came out obviously I was you know
talking to a lot of the top con artists
um and they were all Psychopaths there
was a chapter in that book called
natural born persuaders
um which was all about how psychopaths
are
better at persuading in general than the
rest of us they've got that charm that
Charisma but also they're not caught up
in the emotion of persuasion they're not
caught up in that heat and light you
know then they're not involved in it
which enables them to be able to stand
practice passionately and kind of almost
move you around the court of social
influence like a like a top tennis
player
um
and
um it was that chapter when the book
came out for review
um that all the reviewers kind of zoned
in on and they said well if psychopaths
are better than at persuasion than the
rest of us then what else are they good
at
um and it was then that that chapter
then I didn't actually think there was
enough for a book on Psychopaths but it
was my agent that said I think there may
well be
book on Psychopaths here because of the
work I was doing at the time and I as a
writer you know you have to sometimes
when you get an idea you have to work
out is this a full book or is it like a
5 000 word Sunday supplement article and
I actually thought it was a 5 000 word
Sunday supplement article but he
persuaded me no I think there might be
more in it than that
um and it turned out there was there was
a heck of a lot more in it than that and
turns out the psychopaths are very good
at a lot of things but when the book
came out of course a lot of people at
the time thought it was very
controversial and that's because they
didn't know what a psychopath really was
they'd look to Hannibal Lecter they'd
seen it all on the media and they
thought Psychopaths were rapists serial
killers and and suicide bombers
um so that was the first reason the book
was controversial the general probably
didn't really know what a psychopath was
and secondly the clinicians
um the medical experts couldn't couldn't
countenance the possibility
that there could possibly be benefits to
Psychopathic characteristics at Large
because of course it makes sense you
know if the only Psychopathic they had
seen were the were the bad ones that
have been referred to them from forensic
or clinical settings so you know by
their very nature of their job they
weren't going to meet
um the top surgeons or the Special
Forces soldiers or the the the the CEOs
or the or the people that I that I've
met I'd met the bad ones but I'd also
met the good ones
um so when that book came out that's
when
um I think it's still to my knowledge
the only book that um that that that
argues that actually there are benefits
to Psychopathic characteristics
um and I think it took a while but I
think most people now would would agree
that I've won the argument I think most
of my peers there's there's always going
to be some disagreement but at the time
it was very much like a punk Theory with
like a Mohican and spiky hair and you
know ripped jeans and all they're like
you know all that kind of thing now I
say it's like um it's a theory that's
settled into the comfortable middle age
with pipe and slippers and Same by the
fire but it's still a bit anarchic well
right you came up with the concept of
the good psychopath and but the reason I
asked you about the willingness to
inflict harm is you said No Remorse yeah
these con menud interviews had no is
that an important definitional quality
obviously it is yeah now this ability to
do something that other people may not
like and not care absolutely right now
if we're looking at it in terms of bad
Psychopaths you could say Yes No Remorse
can be used obviously to inflict great
harm and we can see it you know we don't
need to look very far to see that in
society on both the local and the world
stage
but if we look at it in terms of say
good psychopathy we can see that in
utilitarianism so the ability to make
really tough decisions uh which not a
lot of people might be able to make
um but actually that people who are able
to dial those dials up and down on the
mixing desk are able to handle so
when the wisdom Psychopaths came out
people you know who were you know the
the haters as it were were saying
dutton's trying to you know glamorize
Psychopaths actually I wasn't trying to
glamorize Psychopaths at all what I was
saying is that there are certain
Psychopathic characteristics
that in the right context in the right
combinations at the right levels and
Constantine to answer your question with
the right intentions can predispose you
to success and also benefit society and
so rather than trying to glamorize
Psychopaths where the argument started
to turn was when I turned it round on
people and said I'm not trying to
glamorize Psychopaths at all but perhaps
what you're trying to do is stigmatize
them
because actually you know the way if you
if you start from the premise that
psychopathy is a psyche psychological or
psychiatric disorder how many other
disorders would you talk about like that
you wouldn't talk about people with
depression like that or anxiety like
that or Asperger's like that or um aspd
um um
uh potential deficit disorder like that
or schizophrenia like that add that's
what I'm trying to think about aspd's
antisocial personality disorder which is
people often um confuse that with
Psychopaths you wouldn't you wouldn't
talk about any other
um psychological condition like that so
why are you talking about Psychopaths
like that why are you saying that they
are all bad you are in a sense
stigmatizing the surgeon that might well
save your life he might not be the most
empathic person you've ever met in your
life he may be an arrogant narcissist
but actually he might just be the guy
that's cool enough under pressure and
he's able to take the risk to remove
that the appropriate risk to remove that
life-threatening tumor so when when
people started saying I'm glamorizing
Psychopaths I kind of subtly changed it
I think what you're doing is
stigmatizing him and that was the kind
of pivot where the argument started to
to change a little bit I think in order
to uh to reach in an elite level at any
profession whether it's sport whether
it's performing politics medicine
do you need to be a psychopath or a very
high and have very high Psychopathic
traits I think in a lot of cases yeah I
mean it's really interesting so I
brought along
um a few uh years ago when I was writing
with my Psychopaths I did a survey
called the Great British psychopath
survey and the survey was unique uh in
the sense that what I wanted to find out
was what were the most Psychopathic
professions in the UK so I was on a
radio show and we decided to launch this
on a radio show now the the survey
wasn't done very scientifically because
I didn't actually think it was going to
be that big but it turned out it was
quite big uh indeed
um so what I did I said to people right
here's a little test and we might do
this test on you guys we will okay
um to find out where you are on the
psychopathic Spectrum but what I would
also like you to do is just jot down
your occupation so what I wanted to do
was I wanted to
um correlate occupations with
psychopathy levels and it became known
as a Great British psychopath survey
um and the results are really
interesting
um uh yeah
um
so you will be very grateful to know the
stand-up commanders aren't in here
um but that's because there's not enough
of them around yeah statistic to be
statistically valid you've got to have
enough people saying that that's why
politics aren't in apologies a lot of
people are obviously know all about
politicians uh well of the common
professions yeah these are the top ones
a friend of mine always talks about
politicians and says you know actually
of course well you know even I say you
know in order to be you know if you're
if you're going to be a politician
any kind of politicism is going to be
pretty high on the psychopathic Spectrum
even the ones you think are nice yeah
um and a friend of mine says the key is
in the word politics it's derived from
two words Polly uh the ancient Greek
many many and ticks being blood [ __ ]
so anyway but anyway back to the survey
yes
um number one with CEOs yep yep perhaps
not surprisingly number two lawyers yep
um number three media TV radio yeah
that's not such a big surprise actually
because it's a very Cutthroat World
currencies ideas it's very easy to Nick
ideas and you've got a lot of times
you're in a state of flux
um things in a state of flux you've got
to think quickly sales people perhaps
not surprisingly surgeons were number
five surgeon's really interesting
actually
um because
um
I did a talk once and I presented this
table
and there was a surgeon in the audience
who came up to me afterwards and he said
Kev uh I've got no doubt that actually
surgeons are in there but I think
actually you could be a bit more nuanced
here because there are now I think it's
about 12 or 13 different sub-disciplines
of surgery within the surgery bracket
and he said I think you might find that
some
uh brackets might be higher than others
um and we were going to run a study to
find out whether that was the case
um but various things got in the way
covid being one of them uh we may well
do this next year uh but his hypothesis
his hunch was the the uh three uh
surgical disciplines it would be most
homo Psychopathic Spectrum would be
Neurosurgery
cardiothoracic and orthopedic surgery
orthopedic surgery is pretty brutal if
you've seen orthopedic surgeons at work
they have to really do some pretty nasty
things to me you know and if you see
those you know I have 24 hours in a e
and you've got some with a broken bone
they've got to kind of twist that you
know even though the person's in under
analysis say local anesthetic but
they're still feeling it you've got to
be able to do that that's not you know
not everybody can can do that but he he
reckon that neurosurgery cardiothoracic
and orthopedic surgery would be the top
three
neurosurgery is very interesting because
neurosurgery you've got it's the only
branch of surgery where if you make a
mistake in the brain you could leave a
person permanently disabled or blind or
incapacitated or kill them of course but
in terms of like leaving the the kind of
the corollaries the the of of of
invalidity that you could leave a person
in if if an operation doesn't go well
there's no other branch of surgery
really like that and the you know
margins of error between crucial
capillaries is very very small
um
so that's when you're a hot
cardiothoracic surgery obviously
um and Orthopedics
um I spoke to one surgeon uh when I was
writing wisdom of psychopaths and I said
well you know what is the what's the big
difference between people that are great
in surgery and people who are just
merely good and he had no hesitation
I've spoken to other surgeons about this
no hesitation talking and he answers
straight away he said it's the ability
to make a crucial decision under
pressure
it's not technical ability
um a lot of consultant surgeons will
admit that actually the people who are
studying under them uh some of the
junior surgeons are actually technically
better
um but it's the ability to make a tough
call Under Pressure it's decision making
that separates out the top surgeons from
the the surgeons that aren't so great
um
interesting just come back to lawyers
who are number two and then I'll go
through the rest of the list
um it's really interesting so lawyers
I'd interviewed a lawyer when I was
writing uh flypnosis which was the book
prior to wisdom of psychopaths and again
it was the same question what's the
difference between a great law and a
good lawyer and this guy
with a a pupil Master which is basically
like he ran his own Chambers in central
London
um and the chambers it was like a
teaching it was like a teaching Hospital
only in law these are chambers where
people come in from you know your
universities with your first class
degrees in law to learn how to be a
barrister
uh so he said well Kevin said you know
if people are coming to the into the
chambers he said they're all the top
people from you know your top
universities he said so the ability to
um get your head around a a crucial case
very very quickly all the detailed
nuances of it that's a given that's just
entry level having like a photographic
memory again same thing he said High
Intelligence obviously
um he said but the one thing that
separates out a great lawyer from a good
lawyer is something you really can't
teach and he said it's the ability to
tell a story naturally
and he said I'll never forget this and
this is really interesting this is again
why psychopaths are very good at
persuasion he said you know what he said
information travels around the brain
like electricity around a circuit takes
the path of least resistance
so if you and I come up against each
other in court and the jury's over there
and you are able to present the pieces
the facts of the case you are able to
arrange him in a format that makes them
travel around the brains of the jury
faster than my Arrangement you're going
to win
whether you're right or wrong that's the
way it works so uh that was so you can
see why law is number two you see why
surgeon number five uh journalists
number six
uh the police number seven that's not
too surprising
um actually you know some police work
you know you've you know you've got to
be pretty tough you've got to you know
you've got it's you know some some you
know when you're on front line or you're
investigating certain things you've got
to be you know you can't be shrinking
violet really in the police a lot of
evidence to show that um
people that work in so-called hero
professions which are police the
ambulance and the Emergency Services
um and the military are higher on the
psychopathic Spectrum uh than the
general population uh now off skip eight
because we'll come back to eight number
nine is chefs
that is worrying yeah uh but again if
you think you know high pressure yeah
closed environment you've got a lot of
heat you've got a lot of pressure you
seem to manage you're gonna absolutely
right that's one yep accidentally so
chefs and number 10 this is why the
surveys kind of fell down a little bit
civil servants so that that's a catch
all that could be anything but that's
because because I didn't think it was
going to fly the the categories of
professions weren't that great I have
run an experiment again get more results
next year
um and a couple of million people filled
it out online so we'll have a we'll have
a proper look at this next year but
we'll come back to number eight
number eight the clergy church people he
didn't you didn't expect that yeah
um now I didn't at the time
in hindsight a few years have passed now
since this came out
in hindsight it's not that surprising
because a lot of scandals have come out
about the church uh also the church The
more I've looked into it it's just like
pretty much any other business
um and it involves power over people
there is an uncontroversial phrase and
the church is like it is well I'll tell
you something even more chilling
Constantine I mean there was a church
person quite an eminent Church person
who I interviewed once and he turned
around to me he said one of the most
chilling things anyone had ever said to
me and he says Kev I don't believe in
God I'm just good at him
now that is chilling I don't believe in
God I'm just good enough now that is
pretty awful now I'm not digging church
people out because of course there's
always rotten apples in every barrel but
that was a pretty chilling thing if you
can manipulate God so that allows you to
have power over other people
that's pretty Psychopathic
um and of course you know like I said it
is church it's like any other business
says power hierarchies there's all kinds
of things and you're going to go up the
ladder using the techniques that you
would use in any other businesses that
you happen to be good at God then you're
going to get up there the world is run
by Psychopaths but God himself is pretty
much a psychopath I mean if you look at
the Old Testament you know all that kind
of fire and brimstone and all that and
uh you know I think if we if I maybe I
will maybe if I were to profile god
um uh I think um Saint Paul I profiled
um uh so a bit of background on that so
obviously spending years at University
of Oxford and Cambridge are surrounded
by some of the world's top biographers
of famous historical personages and I've
often been fascinated by psychopaths in
history
um and uh wondered how you know famous
historical personages might fare on the
psychopathic Spectrum so it dawned on me
that actually biographers are famous
people
um famous historical people obviously
know these people almost well I would
say virtually better than they know
themselves
um so I thought if I gave them a
specially validated psychometric
questionnaire
um which is developed to detect
psychopathy not in forensic populations
but in members of the general public
there's different tests for that and got
them to fill it out on behalf of their
subject not on behalf of themselves but
on behalf of their subject we'd probably
get a very accurate portrayal of where
certain people featured on the
psychopathic Spectrum
and uh Saint Paul
was actually quite high on the
psychopathic Spectrum the founder of
Western Christianity between before we
turned into stained glass Saint Paul was
a ruthless bastard I mean he he
basically he was guilty of genocide of
course you know he was before the you
know the road to Damascus he was
persecuting uh Christians in large
numbers
um so some Paul himself the founder of
Western Christianity is very high on the
psychopathic spectrum because in the
Gates of Heaven he's at the gates of
heavens and Paul he's got the keys and
Peter oh that's the one sorry
Psychopaths don't have very good
memories
I wasn't that happy note why don't we
find out can people follow along with
this test that we're gonna do oh yeah
yeah sure let's do the test yeah so um
we're psychos and let's find out if
you're a psycho and you're a psycho
people can follow up follow up with this
test uh they can they can play along as
we go do we need to make notes on our
phones yeah what are you going to need
you're gonna need a piece of paper or a
mobile phone
uh because what you're gonna what you're
gonna do is you're going to score I'm
going to read you out 11 items okay 11
simple items and these items all
hypothetically describe you as a person
okay and what you're gonna do you are
going to score each item according to
how accurate a description you think
this is of you okay and you're going to
do it according to the following scoring
key okay so four point scale going from
zero to three okay if you strongly
disagree that the statement describes
you strongly disagree give yourself zero
right if you disagree
give yourself one if you agree give
yourself two and if you strongly agree
give yourself free so it goes from zero
strongly disagree one disagree two agree
three strongly agree okay and I'm gonna
read through them you're gonna score it
as we go along right
number one
I rarely plan ahead I'm a spur of the
moment kind of person I rarely plan
ahead I'm a spur of the moment kind of
person so zero strongly disagree just to
recap one disagree two agree three
strongly agree and number two
cheating on your partner is okay so long
as you don't get caught
now whenever I do this with students in
universities in large numbers this is
always the one where people are looking
over their shoulders think what the
other person said uh 200 points okay as
long as you don't get caught number
three
uh if something better comes along
it's okay to cancel a long-standing
appointment
something better comes along it's okay
to cancel a long-standing appointment
number four
seeing an animal injured or in pain
doesn't bother me in the slightest
number five driving fast cars riding
roller coasters and skydiving appeal to
me
number six it doesn't matter to me if I
have to step on others to get what I
want
number seven I'm very persuasive I have
a talent for getting other people to do
what I want
number eight I'd be good in a dangerous
job because I can make my mind up
quickly
don't think too long about that one
uh number nine
I find it easy to keep it together when
others are cracking under pressure
number ten if you're able to con someone
hey that's their problem they deserve it
and a final one number 11 most of the
time when things go wrong somebody
else's fault not mine don't pin it on me
right so 11 items you should have 11
numbers on a page there gentlemen I want
you to top that up and come to a grand
total don't say what it is yet
got the total there Francis not yet okay
I can see why you never got the job on
countdown mate
you got yours confident in got yours
Francis all right now I'm going to go
through for the folks at home
I'm going to go through what this the
little key on the Spectrum so you can
see where you score
what we should say at this point is
we're not diagnosing anyone here all
right this is just a general indication
of where you are on the psychopathic
Spectrum it's quite accurate but it's
just not we're not diagnosing right zero
to eleven
you are low on the psychopathic Spectrum
have either of you scored zero to eleven
no no no all right okay
right 12 to 17 you are below average on
the psychopathic Spectrum you're the
first now what did you score I've got I
scored 17. 17. that's on the high end of
that that's the that's the border
between below average and average which
is 18 to 22 which is me oh you're in
there right okay what are you 19. 19. I
surprised myself massively oh do you
know what I think P I think was Piers
Morgan 18 or 19 I think peers might have
been 18 or 19. well I'm more
Psychopathic than PS4 well I don't know
Jesus [ __ ] Christ I think you might
be one point higher so agents went 18 to
22 is average uh 20 average your average
yeah yeah you can feel the tension
Rising here 23 or you would do anyway if
people are playing on at home
um the interesting people send their
scores in actually I don't know yeah we
can do and people can post their scores
on our locals and also maybe what they
do for a living would be quite good yeah
so 18 to 22 is average 23 to 28 is high
and 29 to 33 which is obviously quite
rare is very high so that's a very
simple test of where you might feature
on the psychopathic Spectrum so um very
good yeah did you do it no no all right
he was 30. he was 32. so there we go but
you can see yeah I mean yeah but but
also as I say when people talk about
Psychopaths say you know you need to
know what a psychopath is so it doesn't
mean to say you're going to become an
Act if you do score high it doesn't mean
to say you're going to be an ax murder
or anything like that it just depends on
what you do for a living I mean you know
I know quite a few Special Forces
soldiers who are very on the
psychopathic Spectrum surgeons as well
it just depends I mean there are some
situations I mean you you're asking a
question earlier actually France about
um uh which I still probably haven't
quite chance and that is like you know
in order to to be good at anything do
you need to be high on the psychopathic
Spectrum but not everything I mean it
depends what obviously it is probably
not child rearing yeah we'll know
exactly right if your parents are
exactly right but but I mean let's say
something is really interesting like
sport for instance now
um in order to be you know an Olympic
champion or a world champion in any
sport you're going to need to be pretty
high on the psychopathic Spectrum even
the nicest people people I always use an
example like Roger Federer right so
Roger Federer one of the nicest guys you
know but actually if you look at a lot
of these early games when he was
starting off he would he would he would
quite often lose the first set and then
come back and win 3-1 while he was
actually dissecting the person's game he
was looking for the weak spots like a
predator playing with playing with prey
and then he would dismantle that that
person now I would say you know
obviously a very very nice guy in Roger
Federer but were he to behave like uh he
behaves on say Center called in
Wimbledon or in Flushing Meadow
um you know where he behaves like that
in everyday life you know smashing and
slicing his opponents into Oblivion he'd
soon find himself in a very different
kind of court right so in order when you
get at the higher echelon sport
Talent is often quite similar it then
comes down to how badly you want it how
ruthless you are whether you are
prepared to push yourself into the black
into the darkness to really go for it
and I think it was actually another
tennis player John Mcenroe said that you
know in order to be number one at
anything the world has got to revolve
around you uh because if it doesn't then
you know then your opponent if if it
revolves more around your opponent then
it revolves around on you he's going to
come out or she's going to come out on
top there's a lovely story about
Sebastian Cove the um the athlete um
back in the year 1980s
when uh Great Britain were fantastic at
middle distance running uh one of his
um big rivals was Steve ovet who many of
your listeners will remember the co-op
vet rivalry of the early 80s and
um sebco was uh having Christmas dinner
in his parents house in Sheffield one
day and he had just done a seven mile
run
um very hilly run in the morning and it
was an icy wind outside and absolutely
awful weather and he was like nodding
off by the fire after a big Christmas
turkey and dinner and all that and he
suddenly had a very uneasy feeling he
was in the build up to the I think it
was the Moscow Olympics or the maybe the
LA Olympics in 84. and he had this very
uneasy feeling that actually
um Steve his big rival Steve over it
might well have gone out and done a
second session and it was beginning to
pray on his mind and so he thought I
can't let it rest so you know last thing
he wanted to do moved away from the fire
got his kit on and went out and did
another seven miles in in the icy wind
and all that anyway many years later he
met Steve over there at a big function
and Olympic dinner
the two are very good friends now and he
told Steve over at the story and over
its response was oh you only went out
twice on Christmas day so you know
you've got to have that it's a lovely
story and a true one yeah where you know
you've got to have that ruthlessness
everything's got to focus around you and
I think this is really interesting
actually I think when people when when
you hear people say uh you know parents
or cultural leaders say you know
um we you know role models for our kids
should be you know yeah yeah you're Andy
Murrays or your Steve Redgraves or you
know you you're really top sports people
like that actually there's an element of
rule pathology
in being a top level Sport and that's in
no way you know detracting from your red
Graves and your marriage and your
federers and your you know your Tyson
Furies but you have to have that tunnel
vision that single-mindedness that
ruthless pursuit of Excellence to be up
there and what that does is it doesn't
in a lot of cases maybe the the most
rounded of individuals so when we when
when we kind of you know say that we
want to you know we our our kids should
have those kinds of aspirations be
careful what you're wishing for and it's
funny that you should tell that story
about subco because of course famously
after his athletic career he became
equality he did indeed he did he did he
did indeed that's right yeah yeah but
yeah I've um I've done a couple of talks
with that yeah he's uh he's a he's a
very very bright and polish guy you know
well no doubt uh but which brings me to
a question that I think is very
interesting which is is this why
Psychopaths we have psychopath that
they've we've evolved in societies where
we have a certain number of psychopaths
because it's useful to have them we need
you know now it's athletes but in the
past they would have been Warriors and
leaders oh yeah that's right I think
tribe achieves and all I think that's
right if we go back in evolutionary time
uh when we were living in small groups
on the east African savannah
um you know people who were ruthless
warriors were obviously going to be in
high demand
um people who were able to inter
infiltrate other groups and perhaps get
information out of other groups we're
also going to be in higher demand as
well so and also expert hunters and
predators were going to be in high
demand as well so those kinds of
Ruthless and fearless Psychopathic
traits it's not difficult to see how
they may well have evolved and also the
ability to persuade to reduce conflict
and trouble in a group without getting
caught up in the heat and light of the
emotion itself you can see how that
might have evolved and all these
characteristics exactly are you know
still we've still got pretty much the
same brains now as we had back in those
days
so you can see how those traits are
still valuable today
um so you're absolutely right constant
and that's why these characteristics are
still knocking around but there's a much
more prosaic answer to that question as
well and that is by their risk-averse uh
um nature uh they're they're sorry
they're less risk-averse nature uh
psychopath more promiscuous
um so there's a lot more Psychopathic
genes knocking around than there would
be non-psychopathic genes
um so actually because they tend to have
more offspring
um and they tend to be more sexually
promiscuous uh it's another reason why
psychopathy is still hanging around in
the in the general population so not
only do they have more kids but actually
in the right context
um these kinds of characteristics can
predispose you to success and are are
valuable where they become toxic is if
we go back to the mixing decile analogy
and you have those dials just slammed up
on maximum and you can't regulate them
um according to context so as I was
saying if Roger Federer was as ruthless
on Center core uh was as ruthless in
real life as is on Center called at
Wimbledon as I say you'd end up in
another kind of court that would be the
equivalent of having those mixing
deciles jammed up on maximum so good
Psychopaths with my my
terminology are people that are able to
dial those dials up in the right context
when it's needed and use those
characteristics for the right intentions
but are able to dial them back down uh
when needed
um and people that have them jammed up
on Max all the time they're the people
who are toxic they're the people who are
going to end up in prison they're the
eight people and it also links up with
intelligence as well so if you are a
violent stupid psychopath you are going
to be
um probably going to commit a violent
crime and you're going to be caught very
quickly and put in prison rightfully so
however if you are uh an intelligent
psychopath that say had a good start in
life
um and maybe you're not even naturally
violent then as the famous reuter said
lime once put it you're more likely
going to make a killing in the market
than anywhere else
um and then if you're if you're a
psychopath intelligent and maybe
naturally aggressive then any number of
exotic occupations might await you
anything from
um well Special Forces operative to
maybe the head of a criminal Syndicate
something like that so there's all kinds
of there's all kinds of other variables
in the personality cupboard so you might
be a psychopath but you might not be
violent and you might be intelligent
that might predispose you to success in
say business all the markets or
something like that if you are a
psychopath you are violent and you're
not that intelligent then you might just
be caught up as a you know as a violent
criminal
um uh so there's a lot of other things
and then and then you get into like you
know people often
where the serial killers come into this
kind of thing not all psychopaths are
serial killers not all serial killers
are psychopaths so you know
um it's very interesting I mean but if
you are a psychopath and say you had
formative experience which wasn't so
great say you were sexually abused or
violently abused or emotionally abused
and you also had a psychopathic
personality then that might predispose
you into say serial crime I always use
the analogy of a bullet and a gun
so
let's say that the bullet in a gun is
your DNA if your genetic predisposition
could be anything but let's talk because
we're talking about Psychopaths let's
say it's the genetic predisposition to
be a psychopath is a bullet in a gum
um that genetic predisposition that DNA
won't become live unless there's a
finger on the trigger to make that round
life to fire the gun and that finger on
the trigger would be a formative
experience in your childhood so as I say
it could be emotional sexual or violent
abuse
um that might then trigger you into a
life of crime
um if you are say Psychopathic and you
have an experienced perhaps in your
Early Childhood where sexual arousal is
paired with seeing someone in distress
or seeing someone in pain
and as I say that's paired with a
psychopathic personality
then there may be a chance that that
could escalate and so you go you you you
start on the road of fantasy and you
fantasize with that but then when you
come to the end of that fantasy Road
somebody who might not be Psychopathic
may think well okay that's the end of
the road but somebody who is less
risk-averse May well then say well okay
what do we do now well let's start
reenacting this in real life and then
you're into the criminal element maybe
serial crime or something like that so
that's the relationship so the
relationship between psychopathy and
crime is actually more complicated than
it than it might seem
hey Francis if you were a member of the
public would you like the opportunity to
ask incredible guests like Bill Burr
Jordan Peterson Sam Harris Adam Carolla
Brett Weinstein John Barnes Douglas
Murray Nigel farage and Lionel Shriver
your own questions you bet I would and
what do you think the best way to do
that would be uh probably stalking mate
you'd have to Corner them in the
supermarket probably around near like
the sort of frozen food of and then just
bought questions at them before they can
escape not the American ones as they
have guns and you'd have to be extra
careful with the females as that's how I
got in trouble last time do you really
imagine you're gonna get Douglas Murray
near the frozen food aisle if you want
to ask our incredible guest questions
and have access to phenomenal behind the
scenes content then you have to be on
our locals that's right for only seven
dollars a month you get incredible extra
content behind the scenes footage
giveaways and also the chance to be part
of an incredible Community where you can
meet and hang out with like-minded
people you get access to our American
Vlogs as we travel across the country
interviewing Our Heroes an extra 20
minutes of our viral Sam Harris episode
as he discusses his approach to covert
we're also going to start doing
giveaways of exclusive trigonometry
merchandise like this a poster from our
Edinburgh show signed by both of us and
also a House of Lords Teddy which you
can only get in the House of Lords
signed by the one and only baroness Fox
locals also gives you access to an
incredible online community you can
share memes talk about the latest
episode or even make a new friend or
just one exactly more than both of us
have really people are now doing meetups
in their City because they love locals
in fact some people enjoy it so much
they prefer it over the show they prefer
locals to trigonometry
if I have to get them executed I'm the
one that goes to jail right go to
trigonometry.locals.com only seven
dollars a month for all that incredible
content
trigonometry.locals.com See you there
guys
what is the link between narcissism and
psychopathy are those are people who are
psychopaths more likely to be
narcissistic and vice versa yeah I mean
Kevin maybe Define narcissism for us in
a professional way because we'll it's I
think it's like psychopathy people use
the term without necessarily
understanding what it means so Define it
before you answer it yeah narcissism is
basically it's a personality disorder
like psychopathy
um so there's something called the dark
Triad the dark Triad is consists of
three uh personality disorder which are
all actually linked where if you
remember the old Venn diagrams when we
were kids the old circles if you were to
draw the circles between narcissism
psychopathy and something called
machiavellianism which is the ability to
like manipulate people and you know act
as bit of like an emotional Puppeteer
for your own benefits there's a lot of
overlap between the two so narcissists
are people that are very very Grandy
have a very grandiose view of themselves
they're egocentric love to be the center
of attention
um now the interesting thing there is
while you're smiling there
recognize yourself never know
um but the interesting thing there is
egos Machiavellian egocentricity is
actually a trait found in Psychopaths as
well
so a lot of psychopaths are going to be
narcissistic but not all narcissists are
going to be Psychopathic that's the way
the variation and I'll tell you why
that's where we are mate because
I'm more Psychopathic than Piers Morgan
so I've not come out of this well anyway
carry on no so well what it is is the
fact that so a narcissist just in
general to keep it simple narcissists
will want to be the center of attention
because that is the end goal for them
they want to be the center of attention
they want to be in the Limelight they
want to be recognized they want all the
Kudos it's all about them they want to
be on stage that's the narcissist right
a psychopath
doesn't necessarily need that a
psychopath doesn't need to be the center
of attention for its own sake but it's a
means to an end for a psychopath so for
a psychopath being the center of
attention being in the Limelight
gives them access to power which is what
they do want psychopaths are into power
and if being the center of attention is
the primary way of getting that power
then that's what they will do but it's
not the end it's a means to an end
whereas with a narcissist
it's the end goal itself it's so funny
you should say that because Francis and
I we recorded like an end-of-year
conversation between him and I and I
stopped doing stand-up during the uh
basically during the pandemic and and he
carried on and he was saying how much he
loves being on stage where I was saying
well I enjoy being on stage and he was
trying to convince me that you know
stand up yeah whatever and I was like
well the thing is I I never really cared
that much about being on stage and I
never I always wanted to leave a gig I
didn't want to hang around and meet the
adoring fans or anything like that
that's not how I think but I used to
enjoy writing jokes and Performing them
and being on stage and it's funny that
you you make that distinction well it's
interesting because I know a couple of
other stand-up comedians I won't mention
anything and they've said the same thing
and it's it's interesting because
um one stand-up can be I'm not this may
be true for you it may not but one
stand-up comedian who's a friend of mine
saying like they don't like hanging
around meeting fans either
because being on stage is a Persona yes
yes and it's very much about you know
you are very funny on stage but actually
when you're off stage actually you can't
be that funny all the time so it's
almost like they don't want to let the
fans down they don't want to like access
to the real person so that was the kind
of the the motivation for for them which
is quite interesting so it's really you
know when you think of like stand-ups
you think they're like they're funny
like that all the time you know their
wife's cracking they're making everyone
laugh but you know as you know it's very
hard work as you've experienced your day
but it's very hard work and it's you
know you've got to you've got to work at
an app like that so so one one of as I
say one of the friends of mine said
actually I don't like meeting fans they
prefer to keep it as the Persona on the
stage which is totally understandable
but uh suppose if you're not that funny
France
but Kevin is it possible to be a
psychopath and live a good life
yeah I think it is um I think if we come
back to what we're saying if you if you
go back to the the the the mixing desk
Styles
um
I think if you are if if all those dials
are turned up to maximum all the time
then you're not going to live a good
life okay but if you are if you've got
some of them turned up high and some
down low depending on the circumstances
then I think it is another way of
looking at it would be to say well think
of psychopathy as being like going back
to Athletics think of it being like a
decathlon or a heptathlon so a
heptathlon decathlon you've got seven or
ten events that comprise the entire
discipline
um so if you look at psychopathy as
being you know a condition comprising of
various psychological traits such as
ruthlessness fearlessness lack of
empathy lack of conscience Charisma all
those kinds of things coolness under
pressure
um if you're good at the right
disciplines then it's possible to live a
good life
but if you're good at good at the wrong
disciplines if you know you've got
conscience and empathy turned down low
all the time
then it's not possible to lead a good
life so it all depends as I say on what
you use those characteristics for
um so good friend of mine the the
Special Air Service guy Andy McNabb I've
written a couple of books with Andy I
mean he's he's a he's a he came to my
lab in in a few years ago and we plugged
him into a load of computers that went
ping and did the psychometrics on him uh
very very high on the psychopathic
spectrum and it made absolutely perfect
sense to him when he found out all his
life suddenly started he actually said
you know now it makes sense
um
and Andy leads a very good life
um he's but you know as I say he's
ex-special forces those characteristics
um
predisposed him to great success
um very cool Under Pressure can be very
ruthless
um but he can turn it on and off when he
has to I mean I'll give you a great
example I always remember going down to
um a gastropub once me and my my
immeasurably Superior other half a lane
went down to a gastropub uh to watch the
England World Six Nations rugby match
with him and uh his missus
and we went to this Pub and it had
opened at something like 11 o'clock the
game was at three in the afternoon
something like that and um we uh we got
in there about two we were gonna get
some drinks get some food and watch the
game when we went in there there were
four Welsh guys about six foot three six
foot four standing at the bar they'd
obviously been on the Lash since the
place at openly eleven o'clock they were
really no parts of Guinness leather
jackets big old boys you know and um
they were Effingham blinding right now
no one's approved you know No One's
Gonna really worry about that but they
were women and children around
Jeff and they were very loud it just
wasn't the kind of right occasion for it
so Andy said to me he said right you go
and get the drinks I'll go and get the
food
so I said fine okay so it was kind of
one of these bars where the food was
served in a different kind of place to
the
drink so I've gone round one side but
I'm not too far away but from here to
where Anton is going and he's gone
around this side where these four guys
are so I could kind of hear and he
wasn't showing him up he said excuse me
Lads look not don't want to ruin your
day or anything but look can you just
turn the volume down a little bit uh and
they're all kind of leaning over the bar
like this and one of them put his Pine
down and it's kind of stood up squared
up and I thought this is going to be
interesting because Andy's not a big guy
he's about he's broader than me it was
about my height about five nine five ten
I thought this was going to be
interesting so
I've gone round to his side of the bar
for one and a half against four score
so I've gone around there and I'll never
forget it chaps he he kind of Lent
forward yeah
you know it wasn't showing anyone up he
kind of put his hand very gently on this
guy's forearm he said okay right he said
here's what's going to happen
he said the door is over there he says
you you you and you never pointed at any
of them right open hand because pointing
is inflammatory you you and you and you
you're gonna put your points down
and you're gonna walk through that door
and you're gonna remain on the other
side of it very very polite you're gonna
rain on the other side for the duration
of the game
and he said oh no forget it and it's
something in his eyes just went into
Arctic blue eyes and they just
absolutely changed and he said because
if you don't I'm going to formally
introduce you to a level of physical
violence you never knew [ __ ] existed
and there's no tax or exaggeration on
that line that's exactly how it went and
there was a moment of quiet reflection
and these chaps just filed out in line
and that was the end of that but here's
where it gets interesting you would
imagine that after that you know if it
was a normal person there'd still be
kind of Pumped up but it was literally
like a tap going on and off like a
switch on and off and it was right right
Kev fish and chips twice a pizza and
burger wouldn't it simple as that
business as usual like nothing can
happen it was what we call instrumental
it was right this is how this is going
to end this is how it's going to pan out
um that's what you're going to do the
situation is sorted now
I became very interested after that
particular episode I became very
interested on remaining on the right
side of anime
I became very interesting because I'm
sure you're there already well can you
fake that do you there was no doubt in
my mind or in Andy's mind that he would
have like totally dismantled those guys
had it come to that no one wanted a
fight in a gastro pub but actually if if
it had come to that he could have done
it but what I became very interested in
was is it possible to fake that do you
need to be the real deal or can you
actually act that part and we were going
to run a study looking at that I can't
go into too many details now because
kovid scuffled it uh but hopefully we
will get around to looking at it next
year to see whether you actually do need
to be the real mccoya or whether it's
possible for anyone to kind of method at
their way into that kind of role
um so um
yeah
into more detail about that yeah quick
question are psychopaths
are a lot of them in control of their
character traits and personalities like
you talk about them being dull you know
certain people being dolled up to Max
and some people not and yeah can they
actually control it yeah somebody like
like Andy can
um again the bad ones can't the ones who
end up in prison because they can't
control it and if there's one of those
dials so we've got two analogies going
here um we got the mixing desk Styles
and we've got the decathlon heptathlon
thing
um there's one major difference between
what we might call good and bad
Psychopaths
uh and it's depending on whether you
want to use the athletic analogy or the
mixing decile analogy
um it's the impulsivity dial or the
impulsivity discipline in the Teflon
decathlon
um if you are impulsive
and a psychopath which is one of the key
traits in psychopathy if you've got that
dial turned up and you can't control
that that's the answer to your question
then you're going to wind up in a lot
and if Andy had had that that would have
been a fight exactly exactly right then
then you're getting into the realm of
what we call this is one of the majors
I'm glad you asked from that Ashley
Francis because it's a major
um theoretical point
this is the difference between again in
general chance between sociopathy and
psychopathy all right so a lot of people
say well what's this are the terms
interchangeable well a lot of time when
they're used in the media excuse me
they're interchangeable
um but actually if we're looking at it
you know professionally likely
technically
sociopaths are people that
um are impulsive
who are violent a lot of the time who
react rather than respond so give you an
example let's say that
um we met in a bar let's say uh let's
say that I was a sociopath and uh you
happen to annoy me in some way let's say
you walked in him and Spilled my drink
um if I was a sociopath and I just got
annoyed at that I might pick up a box
and smash it over your head
um react violently like that I might
then be carted off to the Nick and I
might in the morning uh really regret
that I might show remorse for that
um however if I was a psychopath and you
did that and let's say I also saw 200
quid in your wallet
I might not react at all I might just go
okay that's interesting but I might be
waiting for you outside the pub with a
knife
and I might use that knife
instrumentally to get that money out of
you
so
psychopaths are capable of very cold
premeditated violence whereas sociopaths
the impulsive kind of hot-headed
anti-social personality
um is more predisposed to reactive
hot violence than cold premeditated
that's very interesting and Kevin am I
right in thinking that there are more
male Psychopaths than female yes that's
true
um just going back to come back to that
point a minute just a point on on the
previous thing no no no fine um on the
previous Point
um it's really interesting one very bad
psychopath who I interviewed in a secure
unit once uh came up with a very good
way of looking at it and he said again
very very chilling he said you know what
there's
um when you stop at a traffic light red
Amber and green you don't need to have
color vision to know how that works you
just need to know which bits are lit up
and that is very much how Psychopaths
pure Psychopaths not the sociopath
Psychopaths see emotion they don't see
the color of it they see which bits are
lit up which means that they're very
good at moving people around and you
know emotional puppeteering and all that
kind of thing so they they don't hear
the tune they just read the score
if you want to look at it in a music
analogy the gender differences in
psychopathy yes
um so first of all it's important to
remember
that psychopathy pure psychopathy is
rare so it's less than one percent of
the population so there's you know the
old joke about bloats hitchhiking down a
road one dark night and puts his hand
out on a lorry stops for him and he gets
in and he can't believe it and he turns
around to the Lorry driver and he says
I'm amazed you stop for me for all you
know I might be a serial killer and the
truck driver says no chance of the tooth
Feel Again pretty much Lira so I mean
it's like yeah
it kind of gets to the point that it's
pretty rare but within that very rare
bracket yes there are generally more
males and Psychopaths uh again the old
joke is the more male Psychopaths more
sorry more male Psychopaths than female
Psychopaths and again the old joke is
that um generally agreed that women
prefer to kill just the one man over a
longer period
um that's found of me getting canceled
right there by my wife yeah um but yeah
I mean and that we don't quite know why
that is but there's a number of
hypotheses and number of number of
reasons why
early upbringing guys are generally
generally brought up to be more
competitive
um and more Rough and Tumble more
aggressive so that might be one reason
another reason is that
um male and female brains tend on
average to react differently to aversive
stimuli so if you are if you come into
the lab and you you're a female and you
um say are subjected to Electric shocks
or white noise or something like that
you may well be more predisposed to be
anxious whereas a male brain may be more
predisposed to be angry so there's a
kind of a slight difference there
between how
maniformal brains react to verse of
stimuli
um possibly one of the more interesting
uh theories is is actually that there
it's a kind of a socio-cultural theory
that there may well be a bias in
diagnosing women because the word
psychopath has a pejorative it's got a
negative connotation and in somewhere
like America for example it has legal
connotations as well which can result in
the difference between getting the death
penalty or not in some states so there
may well be a bias in clinicians to not
diagnose as many women as men and also I
think to a lot of people psychopathy is
correlated with violence women are less
likely to use violence absolutely right
well that's that and that's another
theory that actually the same brain
States in of that you might get in
psychopathy
in males might manifest a great point it
might manifest itself in a different way
well this is what I was going to ask you
what is the is there a behavioral
difference between your average male
psychopath and the female psychopath
because I think most people have an idea
of what a male psychopath Behavior might
look like yeah what does a female
psychopath look like um there's evidence
to show that in in female psychopathy
may be more akin to what we call
borderline personality disorder which is
um uh narcissism
um manipulation
um mood swings black and white mood
swings if you remember Fatal Attraction
the film Fatal Attraction with Glenn
Close that was a brilliant depiction of
it right there
um so
um as I say you know very black and
white thinking
um manipulation intimidation
um emotional kind of uh blackmail just
describing women that's right yeah
now you've canceled I'm
you know what's interesting you you
talked about borderline personality
disorder we had uh Dr Donna Fleischman
who is an evolutionary uh psychologist
right uh a couple of years ago now and
she was saying more women got diagnosed
get diagnosed with BPD every year
they're men so could it that just be
that these are more just female
Psychopaths
absolutely well that's one one there is
one school of thought which says that
actually the the the same brain State
manifests itself behaviorally in a
different way in females than it does in
males there is there there is a school
of thought which says that so absolutely
I always say you know Francis the brain
is like it's like a mysterious gray
planet and it's you know everyone talks
about landing on Mars
if you think of the brain as a planet a
mysterious gray Planet between our ears
we haven't really landed on it yet we've
just we've seen it through long lens
telescopes right but we it's still a
very new world we actually don't really
know that much about it we're learning
more and more but it's really
interesting when people say oh you know
we're sending a probe out to Mars and
all that we've still got to land on this
planet that's fascinating we're nowhere
near landing on this planet yeah and it
is you know when you see it on the scans
it's like this gray World which is at a
at a distance and you know it's actually
right inside our own head so uh it's
really interesting but I mean I I mean I
have my own background I mean I grew up
with my my own father with a psychopath
that's how I kind of started really he
was um he was a market Trader
um in uh in London uh not in the stock
market on the streets he was he was like
Dell boy I mean he even looked like Del
Boy I would say you could sell shaving
cream to the Taliban
and he was ruthless he wasn't violent he
was ruthless he was Fearless he was
nervous he was Shameless uh but I never
once saw him embarrassed
um and he could do things that most
people would find
psychologically impossible I mean
I always remember one I'll give an
example I mean I remember one time I was
about nine or ten I used to help him on
the stool you know
and uh we got hold of a load of Diaries
once calendar Diaries and they were very
different to anything we got our hands
on before because they were actually
bloody nice right they were leather they
were fake leather anyway they were
embossed they were slim there was a
reason why they were slim anyway we
knocked out about 300 of these in about
an hour and a half on the stall
somewhere in like I remember it wasn't
it was a curry to a pith head you know
these things and when we got back to the
flat
they were fantastic I said yeah but
they're not thin those Diaries weren't
they and this gives an indication what
it's like he said yeah there was a
reason for that Kev I said oh well
thanks as uh April was missing
so when you are he gets one out the
drawer
January February March May
it was exactly ideal what June I said
Dad we've we've just sold 300 of these
what are we gonna do he said I'll never
forget he said nothing for now some but
come the end of March make sure you pack
your swimming trunks because they're off
to torremolinas for six weeks
give a [ __ ] about anything he was like
absolutely no sense of consequence but a
real cheeky charmer cheeky kind of
chappie and he was one of the most
persuasive men he wasn't an educated guy
he left school at the age of 15. but as
I say he was he he was absolutely a
brilliant salesman and he said something
to me which in all my years in Academia
I don't think I've ever heard a more
profound statement about the art of
persuasion and he it was actually one
night it was funny enough it was always
remember it we he was taken into an
Indian restaurant in Brick Lane in the
East End of London and um we just
finished on the stall and um just as
he's about to pay the bill he turns
around to me says Kev if there's one
thing I want you to remember in life son
is this persuasion isn't about getting
people to do what they don't want to do
it's about giving them a reason to do
what they do want to do
right very very different so watch and
learn so I'll never forget it he gets a
spoon and he Tinkles against his glass
the entire restaurant falls on and he
gets to his feet and he makes a speech
right and he says right I'd just like to
thank everyone for coming
now I know that some of you've come just
around the corner some of you come from
a little bit further afield but I want
you to know that you're all very welcome
it's very much appreciated oh there's a
pub across the road called The King's
Arms in which we'll be hosting a little
drinks reception after this it'd be
great to see you all there which point
he starts to clap right so at which
point everyone starts to clap so
pictures of scene we've got an entire
restaurant full of people who've never
seen us before never seen each other
before all applauding wildly because
none I want to be seen as a gay Crashers
the pie you know it works right so as
we're leaving remember I'm only about
nine or ten I can't resist it
we're not really going to the pub are we
and he puts his arm around he says
caution or something but let me tell you
something that lot in the restaurant are
my mate Malcolm he's just taken over his
landlord he'll make a few good tonight
again
no sense of consequence no sense of you
know what might happen but what he'd
done he'd demonstrated his own point
that actually there's something in it
for these people they're going to go to
that publish free drinks there they're
going to get him in there so exactly
that kind of guy so I grew up with this
kind of and I often think that you know
years later I was probably
bottom line of it all I might as well
admit it's probably trying to get to the
bottom of whom the old man was really
well very much on that point Kevin I
think a question that a lot of people
want to ask and I my sense is women more
than men but both probably sexist is
how do you know if your partner is a
psychopath if you're not going to get
them to do an 11 Point test like what
are the red flags for someone who is
yeah Psychopathic particularly in a way
that you'd want to avoid really yeah if
your partner's a psychopath your boss is
a sucker but there are I mean you know
we're not talking about sheer or killing
Psychopaths we're talking about like you
know your common or garden people who
are on the psychopathic Spectrum there
are a few telltale signs
um
psychopaths are very very good at First
Impressions really good at first
impression so if you've got someone that
is really love bombing you from this now
this is a general rule of thumb there
are some actually some very nice people
out there as well so but if you've got
someone who is really love bombing you
from the start and perhaps making you
feel a little bit uncomfortable
no you might want to just start thinking
to yourself okay let's see how this pans
out
if then that goes to emotional
manipulation say you're not responding
to that
so they may then start manipulating you
into feeling guilty that you've let them
down or that you're you're spent pretend
you're preferring to spend time with
your friends rather than them look what
I've done for you you know how can you
make me feel like this look well you
know that's another red flag especially
in conjunction whether I say with the
love bombing in the early stages
um if you're at work and
um you've got someone who is maybe it's
the same person who's who's
um taking credit for your ideas
um so they will you know ask you for a
report or something like that or to to
put together some a presentation and
then they take that and pass it off of
them as their own work without giving
you credit
um that's another Telltale sign
um belittling you in public bullying
uh is another Telltale sign
um
being very very nice to people that are
above you but pissing on people below
them is another so the authoritarian
kind of style of personality is another
sign
um
um what we call emotional puppeteering
so moving people around as if they're
chess pieces
um there's no real empathy there it's
just like what you can do for me that's
another sign so if you've got someone
that's demonstrating all these kinds of
signs I'm sure there will be people out
there that recognize that yeah they're
probably there's a few red flags there I
think and how do you become more like a
psychopath Kevin
how do you become more like a psychopath
well some weird questions
yeah but think about it is that your
takeaway from the interview you're not
Psychopathic enough yeah exactly I need
to be more no but it's a good question
big question yeah I think I'm not
disputing that yeah just curious why
he's asking it because you look at these
character traits yeah and a lot of them
as we've already assessed highly
desirable yeah so how do you how does
somebody who is not high on the
psychopathic Spectrum attain those
character traits without all the other
negative you could start by uh buying a
book which I wrote with Andy McNabb
called the good psychopath guide to
success which is exactly answers that
question of course when the wisdom
Psychopaths came out checks in the post
by the way
um when Psychopaths came out
um people said well this is the
um this is the Popular Science version
where's the self-help version so McNabb
featured highly in with my psychopath so
then
um we got together
um and we decided if it's actually his
idea it was a great idea that why don't
we you know I'm the real deal
um and I'm the expert in it why don't we
write a book together where we pull our
expertise and we we try to help people
who are perhaps not as assertive as they
might want to be
um who are probably more anxious than
they might want to be how do we turn
those dials up a couple of notches to
get them to a to a level
um and there's a number of little little
tricks of the trade I mean it's really
interesting right so imagine I was to
put a plank of wood on the floor let's
say it's a five foot plank of wood and
it's a
10 foot long to 20 foot long and I would
just say Francis I want you to walk
along that flank of wood you'd have no
trouble doing it right
imagine the same plank of wood and I
hoisted it up 20 meters right it's
exactly the same five foot wide ten foot
long and I said now walk along it all of
a sudden you'd think [ __ ]
why it's the same plank of wood you're
still putting one foot in front of the
other you could do it quite well when
it's on the ground but all I'm doing is
hoisting it 20 20 foot in the air 40
foot in the air well you've increased
the price of failure that's absolutely
absolutely right and yeah it's exactly
the same process all you've got to do is
put one foot in front of the other but
all of a sudden what you are doing is
you are now not looking at one foot in
front of the other eye you're looking at
the edges and what could possibly go
wrong well Psychopaths don't do that
this is like penalty shootouts right if
I was going to have a uh if I was to
pick a person to to win the World Cup
for England in a penalty shootout
um I'd pick someone who was very hard on
the psychopathic Spectrum someone has
got absolutely reward Focus tunnel
vision no anxiety decisive bang that's
where it's going to go so a psychopath
wouldn't have any trouble walking over
that plank at 44 it's just the same
process so tip number one
would be to decouple emotion from
Behavior All right so you know a lot of
you know a lot of the times we we
confuse emotion motion clouds our
judgment but actually just kind of
thinking to them okay it's the same
process just do what you're doing you
know don't get caught up in the emotion
of it and you can train yourself to do
that
um it's really interesting it's it
there's a study done a few years ago
which looked at and we've all been there
we all we all kind of differ on this
let's say you're on holiday right
you're at the seaside
um there's the sea
uh first down the beach you've got your
trunks on you're going to go in for a
dip right so you've got people that run
straight in we've all seen them right
people that run straight in Banks dive
in get it out of the way or then you've
got they're called the what we might
call the runners then you've got the
splashes haven't you the people that go
in tiptoe up to their knee up to their
all like that and it's and then finally
after about five minutes now what are
you finally they're getting you a runner
or a splasher oh I just tend to I want
to get it over with you I want to go and
dive in Bosch okay get it all over in
one go Constantine what are you I'm the
same I just dive in you're diving right
okay so there was a study done a few
years ago which actually looked to who
experiences the most pain and it's just
unbelievably it's the splashes right of
course it is of course it is right
because you're aggregating the pain
right actually if you just get it over
within one go you actually experience an
aggregate less pain than if you're kind
of like prolonging it
so what impact does that have on real
life well next time you've got to do
something which you don't want to do
let's say you've got to pick the phone
up and give something bad news or you've
got to do a chore that you don't want to
do what do most of us do we
psychologically Splash don't we we put
it off yeah I'll kind of do that in a
minute
yeah okay yeah I'll do it I'll tell you
what I'll do I'll do it after I've made
a cup of tea more splashing right what
you've got to do is just go straight in
pick the phone up just make the call or
just get straight down and do the job
don't overthink it just do it because
actually you've got to do it anyway
and you're aggregating less pain
than if you just keep putting it off so
there's a very simple discipline just
knowing that fact will help you
kind of just turn that dial up a little
bit another way of doing it would be
like well how many times do you get
people to
ask you to do something let's say in
three months time
and you say yeah I'll do that in three
months yeah okay put it in the diary and
then it gets to three months time
forgot I can't do that now you know oh
yeah we've all been there done
um how do you stop yourself from getting
into those situations well another
little tip that we give is like every
time you're asked to do something right
just imagine it's tomorrow right
do you want to do this is it a benefit
to you are they paying you enough all
these little questions because it's
tomorrow because it one day will be
tomorrow right if the answer to any of
those questions is no and you don't want
to do it we'll say no just fast forward
it to
free months as if it's tomorrow and that
way your diary will be full of things
that you actually want to do
another thing on those lines would be
um
if you're trying to decide what to do
um imagine a rating score between one
and ten right now most people if they're
asked to rate whether they want to do
something
the kind of the Tipping Point is around
seven right seven yeah I kind of want to
do that but
yeah yeah it's sad it's kind of good but
okay right so in order to get away from
that Gray Zone of deciding whether you
want to do something rate stuff you want
to do on a rating scale but miss out
seven just go from six to eight so seven
doesn't exist do you wanna how do you
feel about this six one two three four
five six eight nine ten again you'll
find that you start becoming a lot more
selfish perhaps as a word but maybe you
know just caring a little bit more about
yourself yeah again it forces you into a
more binary decision and again if you're
true to yourself then you'll be honest
and you'll find yourself you know just
doing a few more things that you might
like so very simple
tips and techniques to sometimes it's
okay to put yourself first you know you
say it's okay and I think that's you
know if people that aren't as assertive
people who are a little more anxious
tend not to do that and it's really
interesting I've often found that the
inability to say no
is actually a form of narcissism
now I know that sounds a bit silly but
imagine that somebody says to you oh
Francis will you do this for me and you
say uh you're frightened to say no so
you say uh yeah all right I'll do that
let's have a look at what that means
you are thinking in your mind that you
saying no is going to be way more
important to that person it's going to
have a really bad effect on them well
are you really that important to them is
that what you think you think that you
saying no
is going to really upset them who are
you you probably know one to them so
when people have trouble saying no it's
often an inverted form of narcissism
that you over inflate your sense of
importance to that person
so actually a lot of the time
saying no won't have that effect on the
person at all it's just okay then fair
enough but you see there's a flaw in
your argument because I'm everything to
him
but Kevin
we've taken up a lot of your time
it's been absolutely fascinating before
we go to our locals questions and the
usual final question to ask let me get
the converse question for you which is I
was actually extremely surprised by how
low I was on the on the psychopath scale
because I Am Naturally very low in
empathy yeah so and I've had to so I
guess the question is how do you become
less Psychopathic in a beneficial way to
you because I'll give you an example
I I I've always been self-employed I've
always worked by myself yeah and it's
only when we started doing this and
there was a team of people to manage and
whatever yeah I've ever actually had to
care about what the people around me
think and feel right and to me it
doesn't come naturally and to this day
I'm almost like I feel like
I am
mechanistically yeah getting there like
I know I need to care about the people
who work here yeah because that's how we
get the results we want yeah but if I
could switch that off and everything
just got done without me thinking about
the emotions I would take that option
any day of the way yeah I'm not gonna
lie yeah right so and I've I've got
there over time by consciously focusing
on it and it's been beneficial to me and
and I think to everyone around so how
does one brilliant question address yeah
negative Psychopathic Behavior within
oneself yeah well there's a number of
answers to that question Constantine and
the first thing is actually what you're
describing is interesting that you felt
that you needed to change that because
actually it sounded like being
mechanistic with doing actually just as
well as actually feeling it so yeah oh
yeah it gets the result it gets it gets
the results so if that was if it gets a
result and you were able to like do that
coldly and meccan dispassionately it's
interesting that you felt the need to
actually kind of change and become you
you you wanted to feel it yourself
rather than anyone else feeling it which
is kind of interesting I think so that's
that's an interesting thing
um the reason I feel the need to do it
is I know that we can't get to where we
want to get to without without without
without it being genuine without you
genuinely feeling it no with without
without caring how other people feel
about things yeah yeah yeah well no
that's true that's true what I'm saying
is you can kind of
how can I put it you can kind of care
about how other people feel about things
but there's two ways of doing it you can
coldly care or you can warmly care
actually I personally I don't think
there's much wrong with that to be
honest I mean actually to be honest but
there's a much more um in-depth answer
to your question okay and actually
Psychopaths when you look at empathy in
Psychopaths it's very very interesting
because
there's cold empathy and there's warm
empathy right very very basic
distinction cold empathy is the ability
to calmly and dispassionately gauge what
another person might be feeling that
sounds like something that you're very
very good at
hot empathy is actually feeling what
another person is feeling and that is
something that Psychopaths aren't very
good at but they're better than average
at coldly and dispassionately gauging
coming back to the traffic lights don't
need to see the colors you just need to
know what bits are lit up that's you
describing yourself I think they're to a
certain extent you just need to know
what bits are lit up but actually that
doesn't make your worst driver actually
but what you're saying is that'd be kind
of nice to see the colors but actually
you don't need to see the colors
necessarily I mean you've got a great
setup going here so you've done pretty
well
however
the interesting thing here is it touches
onto the question of treatment whether
now I know you're talking about like you
know people in everyday life but you
know whether psychopaths are actually
treatable or right in forensic and
clinical settings now for a long time
it's been thought that they haven't been
treatable because of the very nature of
who they are psychopaths it kind of
touches on a point you made earlier for
us which I never actually got around to
answering I've now remembered it
Psychopaths have especially when you're
right up the high end of the spectrum
they tend to have very little self in
insight into their condition
and that was if you remember the the
quiz that we did number 11 was um when
most of the time when things go wrong
it's never my fault it's always somebody
else's
so Psychopaths lack of self-insight you
know it's always other people's if
something goes wrong it's always their
problem you know so you'll see this with
like say you know in a very unsavory
um topic but rape for instance a lot of
Psychopathic rapists will say well she
was asking for it I taught her a lesson
you know she won't do that you know they
frame it so there's no responsibility
from them and all the responsibilities
on the victim that's uh that and again
when we were talking about you know in
everyday life in in say office politics
or in relationships whether you can spot
a psychopath that's again we talked
about that victimization
um you know they make themselves a
victim you know where actually you know
it's uh you know it's not it's not your
fault at all
so traditionally it's been thought that
psychopaths are untreatable because
they're very good at
um passing things off as well they're
not responsible they were actually
behaving in the right way and it's just
the situation that made them or you that
made them behave that way and they were
justified in doing that and also
remember they're very good actors and
actresses so you know parole boards or
you know tribunals they're very very
good at telling you what you want to
hear putting on that good face
you know it won't happen again or
whatever whatever the source as soon as
they're out they're back to their old
ways or whatever as soon as they're out
the other side of the Tribunal
so for a long time it's been thought
that psychopaths are not treatable
um however
there's a lovely story which I heard it
almost goes back to flypnosis the art of
persuasion you know Split Second
persuasion
there's a wonderful story I heard about
the prisoner one of Britain's most
violent men Charlie Brunson who you
might be aware of
so Charlie Bronson
um is notorious he's been in loads of
prisons and there's a film band Tom
Hardy played the role of Bronson a few
years ago and Charlie takes a lot of
hostages
um we used to
and
um makes outrageous demands
um
uh so there was one time he took a
hostage Mr prison guard
and the story went something like it was
Charlie had him catch if and he said if
you do one thing wrong or you say one
thing I'm gonna cut your [ __ ] ear off
and this prison guard said oh don't do
that Charlie my glasses will be all
wonky
brilliant line and Charlie Bronson just
laughed and went oh [ __ ] off let him go
now that's really interesting so clearly
there was a way through in that
particular situation now when I hear
those kinds of stories it brings us
right back full circle to how we started
this you know with persuasion are there
keys to every situation is just most of
the time we're scrambling around trying
to find them or is it the case that
actually some situations do not have any
key to unlock it I'm a firm believer in
the former hence flypnosis
now one of the reasons I think this is a
very long answer your question
constantly I'm getting there but one of
the reasons I think why
Psychopaths
uh we believe them to be untreatable
there's another story about an American
mathematician called George Danzig
now George dancer you won't know but
he's he solved two uh
probability statistical equations that
were previously regarded as being
unsolvable
and the reason he says he was able to do
that was because he was an undergraduate
at the time
and he showed up for class late that day
and when he showed up for class the
teacher had already written the
equations on the board
and George Danzig had missed the part
where the teacher in the lecturer had
said these are unsolvable he thought
they were just Coach Works yeah examples
of coursework that had to be done
because he didn't know they were
unsolvable he went away and solved them
and I think this shows the power of
expectation a lot of the things we do is
informed by what we expect yes expert a
power of expectation
really informs how we how confident we
are in the outcomes we expect to get
and I think one of the problems with
psychopathy is we we have this
expectation
that they're beyond the pale that they
they can't be treated and actually I
think that's informing a lot of our
thinking about this now there is a kind
of therapy which does work with
Psychopaths and it's called
decompression therapy
and it's a very intense form of training
and to be fair the evidence shows that
it works with juvenile Psychopaths so
when the brain's a little bit more
malleable not with older Psychopaths and
decompression therapy is because of the
nature of psychopathy because
Psychopaths tend to not fear
consequences they don't give a [ __ ]
about what people say about them they're
very thick skin they don't learn from
consequences if you punish a psychopath
um or you take sanctions against them
for bad behavior they actually become
more entrenched a lot of the time
because they just don't care they will
just react against that and they will
just double down
so that clearly doesn't work and
psychopath Psychopathic prison almost
double
um uh twice as likely to reoffend their
recidivism rates are double that of
normal prisoners in general so the
punishment angle doesn't work however if
you reinforce good behavior
starting off with just very very minor
behavior like you might just smile at me
as walking past in the corridor and you
get a little treat for that little
reward and you then escalate that
reinforcement schedule up to bigger and
bigger forms of behavior there is
evidence that that does work with
Psychopaths and you can turn people
around especially juvenile Psychopaths
now of course there's a criticism of
that and the fact that you're not really
changing the person you're not changing
what's under the Bonnet you're kind of
just modeling behavior that is a Critic
of decompression uh Theory a therapy but
it does show that actually Psychopaths
aren't Beyond The Pale
but to go back to Everyday Life
if you are high enough on this and it's
really interesting with sometimes people
say to me they email me at a web
startling conversation and they say uh
Dear Professor Dot and I'm very worried
about being a psychopath and I instantly
say well you're not a psychopath
but if you if
kind of a self-insight into being that
you might be you know a little bit hard
on the psychopathic Spectrum I think the
first thing it's a great sign you've had
the inside
because you know that actually there
might be a problem and then as soon as
you might be a problem that's the way
into it that's a door into it so resist
what I would always say is resist the
first option let the first impulse pass
and then have a maybe take five minutes
and then consider the second impulse so
that's the main thing so just you know
you might want to do something just
resist that and think okay
it's an academic intellectual exercise
now if I do that which I previously
might have done
how might that pan out
so put yourself deliberately
dispassionately coldly in the other
person's position or in your own
position maybe a couple of weeks down
the line just literally as an academic
exercise plot out the iterations of that
decision
let the first impulse pass
and then go with the second impulse once
you've considered that so it's a
variation on the theme sleep on it
basically but that's the best and most
powerful everyday tool you can use if
you feel that you might have a bit of a
problem fantastic well Kevin we'll ask
you a couple of questions from our
supporters that only they will get to
see the answer too okay but before that
we've got our usual final question which
I can't wait to hear your answer to
which is what's the one thing we're not
talking about as a society that we
really should be
yeah well I I think that one of the main
things which
bothers me in society which doesn't get
a lot of traction is loneliness
I think there are a lot of people out
there
um who are lonely that's very different
to being alone
um a lonely fine for some people but
there are a lot of people out there who
are isolated who are lonely
um I had a friend of mine who I hadn't
seen for a while
um who uh committed suicide during covid
because he ended up on the streets
um
and that made me really reflect on the
fact that there are people who are
falling through the cracks who are very
lonely there is gradual awareness
building on this now
um I actually did I don't know if you're
aware of it I did a thing called the
Metro Marathon challenge back in uh
2021 with a friend of mine John Collins
who's a Great British rower and in order
to raise awareness of people on the
streets and the homeless
um we became the first two people to run
the entire network of uh underground
Metro network of of a major city in one
go
and we slept rough all the time we were
doing it and then so there's 315 State
stations on the London Underground we
ran all of them in one go we got a um
at a um a firm of mathematicians uh
called Kappa Gemini to map out the
shortest route between all 315 stations
and then we did that and then we ran the
London marathon on the final day to top
it off unfortunately for us Transport
for London while we were doing it we did
it in a fortnight
um decided for the first time in 25
years to open up two new underground
stations and we'd already passed those
by the time so when we finished the
London Marathon we had to keep going and
we had to tick off nine Elms and
Battlefield uh which was actually great
because you don't want to stop straight
after Marathon so we kept walking we
ticked them off but it was called the
Metro Marathon challenge we did that to
raise awareness of homelessness and
loneliness
so that is something which is very close
to my heart uh and I think we need to be
aware that there are people out there
who are on their own and who might need
help so
um that's me being very unpsychopathic
so that's that's what I think we should
be talking more about that's a wonderful
answer and Kevin if people want to find
your books if they want to find you
online where is the best place to do
that
um my social media handle is at the real
Doctor Kev or one word uh so that's
insta and Twitter I'm not the best at it
but uh give me a hand come on that's
good
um and my website is
www.drkevendotten.com
well thank you so much for coming on
well I've loved every minute
it's been an absolute pleasure one of
the best best set of questions I've ever
ended that's very kind of you to say
um and thank you guys for watching and
listening we will see you very soon with
another brilliant episode like this one
oral show all of them go out at 7pm UK
time and for those of you who like your
trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys and go to our locals to
see the bonus questions uh with Dr Kevin
Dunham take care
do you think Meghan Markle is a
psychopath how do you know for sure he
says
foreign
[Music]